[MUSIC PLAYING]
BENJAMIN POIESZ: Afternoon,
morning, lunchish.
Welcome, everybody.
Thank you for coming
to talk about battery.
So it's another year,
and I'm here again
to talk to you about power.
It's an ongoing project.
And as you probably
saw from the keynote,
Dave talked about Maslow's--
or his own version,
of the pyramid.
And I think it's actually
like, a lot is in this image.
Battery is foundational
to everything
you're doing on your phone.
Right?
If you don't have
power, you don't really
have any other cool features.
You don't have the camera.
You don't have the assistant.
Battery exists to power
all the other things.
And it's a struggle for
us, and it's a struggle,
I think, for all
of you as well is,
you want to do awesome
things for users,
and you also want to
save power so they
can do those things for longer.
And battery is actually a
really easy problem to solve.
You just take-- just
kill everything.
Fixed.
I'll take my promotion.
It's great.
The problem is, it's obviously
much more nuanced than that.
And that is a struggle that
we have internally, every day,
talking about
power, and what are
the right trade-offs for users?
And that's always a
really hard question.
And we're going to talk
a little bit about that,
and some of the things that
we're building into Android P
to make it a lot easier.
And so the first
thing I want to talk
about is, where is it going?
And this is like, a
horrifically simplified--
I'm sure some of the engineers
out there are like, oh, my god,
he's showing this.
But you have hardware.
Things even like, how much
RAM you have in your device,
cause a persistent drain on
what's happening to that.
So what hardware the
OEM has selected,
what hardware you're
using, how big
your screen is, how
bright your screen is,
all play into that effect.
You have the OS itself.
Is the kernel being
really efficient?
Is it waking up a lot?
Does it have a lot of overhead?
Do you have disencryption?
Is that disencryption
in software or hardware?
Those things all affect, then,
your overall power profile,
the happening under the hood.
The next thing is
apps and services.
And this is where
we're going to spend
a bit of time talking today.
Obviously, what apps you have
on your phone and the services
running on that phone, drive,
power, substantially largely
through the CPU and through
network connectivity.
And then the last one is
the user's interaction
with the device itself.
How they behave.
What applications they use.
How quickly they
respond to notifications
or don't all impact the
overall picture of where
a battery ends up.
Really complicated topic.
We're going to talk largely
about the bottom left
corner today.
But the thing I
wanted just to give,
before we get into that is,
what other things have we done,
and how does the stuff
we're going to talk about
affect the overall strategy?
So we started out with
lollipop, with JobScheduler.
And JobScheduler was
a very powerful tool
to avoid apps just
having to hang out
on services all the time,
processing in the background.
But you could schedule
a piece of work.
You could have
that piece of work
done in a finite amount
of time, and the OS
could then have some variability
on when to schedule it.
Next, we did Doze.
And Doze was largely
targeted at cases
where you have your tablet
or phone, you put it down,
you're not using it,
you put it in a drawer,
and you forget about it.
And hopefully when you pull
it back out and use it again,
a few days later, it
still has a battery.
And Doze was really trying
to target that problem,
and was largely successful
at dealing with that.
We had to go further, though,
and that was with Doze
on the Go, or Doze Light, as
we tend to call it internally,
because it's just faster.
That was targeted at phones.
And like, I have my phone
hanging out in my pocket.
I'm not using it right
now, but I'm moving around,
so I'm not in a drawer.
That is, then,
the next step, was
how do we get that to
be a good scenario.
And Doze on the Go is trying
to look at that scenario,
if your phone screen is off,
you're maybe moving around,
so you're probably not
wanting all your apps
to be quite severely
restricted as full Doze,
but you still need to
be a little bit backed
off normal scenarios
where the screen is on.
We still need to do
more and go deeper.
The next thing was looking
at background limits,
and this was largely targeted at
background services as a whole.
And now we've had jobs
around for quite a while.
We also were looking at
background limits for location,
and trying to figure out
what the right balance
of applications looking at
location in the backgrounds,
versus the foreground,
and should there
be different thresholds
of what is appropriate.
Really good effect with that.
The only downside,
if you will, to what
we did with Oreo was, we needed
to ax the target, the Oreo
SDK--
and I'll talk about
that in a moment--
in order to support this.
And then, obviously,
since we're here,
we're going to talk
about some more stuff
that we've been working on.
The one thing I wanted
to take a moment,
because we're
mostly going to talk
about really cool ML and
other exciting things,
is there was a lot of just
brute force optimization
that the engineering
team has also done.
This was looking at
F2FS system work.
This was looking
at, how do we choose
between whether a
process should be
on a small core or a big core?
Looking at when we
should do CPU boosts
so that you have nice,
buttery smooth sliding,
but you're not
just burning power
when the screen is
on in anticipation
that the user might
interact with the screen.
And these were all a
bunch of things that
had been done over the years.
This is a set that
we just did on P,
and there's probably still more
that we're trying to get done.
And then, the thing
is, there's still
some of those big, big
challenges that are remaining.
And this is what we're
talking about today.
What we noticed
was battery drain
was roughly proportional
to the number of apps
you had on the phone.
Not the number of
apps you were using,
but how many you had installed.
And obviously, that's not ideal.
And so we wanted to
try and remedy that.
We also saw a lot of scenarios
where apps are accidentally
making mistakes.
Like, if you're
working with wakelocks,
you're kind of
playing with fire.
And what happens when
a mistake happens?
And usually, the
battery would suffer.
Also, some developers
would be a really
aggressive with their use case,
and trying to be like, oh,
I must be there all
the time, ready to go,
at a moment's notice.
And sometimes, that might
take an awful lot of battery
to achieve that,
and is that really
in the interest of the
user, and how can we
help balance that back out.
Because the last part is, even
when an app was aggressive
or an app had a
mistake, it wasn't
obvious to the user
as to what to do.
They didn't know, is the
battery menu going to help me?
Does it tell me everything?
Does it catch all the cases?
Some of the cases?
None of the cases?
And even when you saw a high
battery value, now what?
Do I uninstall?
Do I live with it?
Do I call up the developer
and send them a nasty gram?
And so that's something else
we waned to really look into.
And then the very last
one that I mentioned
before is the Oreo SDK, having
apps targeting that SDK to say,
I understand how the
background limits work.
I understand how I can use
jobs and use alarms instead
of using services.
As you probably saw, there was
a announcement late last year
talking about targeting
requirements for applications
on the Play Store.
If you haven't seen that,
please go Google that
and find out about it.
You should be looking at it,
because those requirements are
kicking in later this year.
And that's going to ensure
that, then, on P, the majority
of the apps on your phone
are now running the Oreo SDK,
and all of these features
we're talking about work.
So the high level thing we're
going to talk about here
is a feature called
adaptive battery, which
I think has been talked about in
a few different talks already.
We'll talk about battery
saver, and trying
to make battery saver better.
And then also, additional
restrictions around background
processing that we've
been looking at.
And this is also
how to help users
understand, when
can I make it stop.
Can I have another choice
other than uninstall?
Something in the middle between
live with it and remove it?
And that's like, that
kind of pyramid's
trying to articulate
here, is we all
want a good power efficiency.
Right?
We like batteries
that last a long time.
We want really cool apps.
And we don't want
the user to have
to manage between these things.
Like, do I want cool apps, or
do I want power efficiency?
No one wants to have to be
forced to make that choice.
It's terrifically difficult.
I don't want to make it.
No one wants to make it.
We want it just to work.
And that's what this whole
project has been all about.
And so with that, I'm going
to invite James up here
to talk about the battery.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMES SMITH: Thank
you very much.
BENJAMIN POIESZ: Enjoy.
JAMES SMITH: Cheers.
Hi, everyone.
Good morning.
I'm James I'm representing
the DeepMind team today.
I just wanted to say that
we're really pleased to be here
and working with Android,
and excited about what
we've built together.
So as a user, you shouldn't
have to closely manage
how your apps behave
on your device.
A modern, intelligent
operating system
should just take care of it.
And that's where machine
learning can help.
We've co-developed this
feature with Android
called Adaptive Battery.
It intelligently aligns power
consumption with app usage.
Apps can still run in the
background when they need to,
and users don't need
to micro-manage.
So adaptive battery uses the
concept of app standby buckets.
Every app on the
device is assigned
to one of these buckets.
Each bucket has different
limits on background activity,
and there are four buckets,
ranging from active to rare.
Apps in the rare bucket will
have the most restrictions.
And we use the ML model
to assign apps to buckets
based on their predicted usage.
So, for example, apps
that are predicted to be
open in the next few hours.
I'm here at IO, so I
might be using the IO app.
So the IO app is going to
be in the active bucket.
But in a few days time,
when I'm back at home,
adaptive battery is going
to automatically determine
that I'm unlikely
to be using this app
and put it into the rare bucket,
so it's not unnecessarily
consuming resources
like battery.
So what are the restrictions
that are applied?
Jobs, alarms, Firebase
Cloud messaging, and network
are all restricted in
Android P, depending
on which bucket the app is in.
Apps in the active bucket
have no restrictions,
just like it is today.
Working set has
some restrictions
on jobs and alarms, and
frequent and rare Buckets
introduce restrictions on
the number of high priority
Firebase Cloud messages.
Messages beyond that cap will
be treated as normal priority,
so that we batch together with
other messages to save battery.
Generally, as
developers, you should
assume the background
activity will
be deferred and ensure
that your app can
work under those conditions.
But one thing to remember
is that once this device is
plugged into power, all of
the restrictions are lifted.
There are adb
commands that you can
use to test your app in
each bucket to make sure
that it performs as expected.
You can also use
new framework APIs
to get your app's current
bucket at runtime.
Most apps should be
fine if they're already
following best practices, such
as using jobs for background
work and targeting recent API
levels like Android or Oreo.
As Ben just said, this is
going to be a requirement
for app updates on the
Play Store later this year,
so please make sure you're
targeting the latest SDK
versions.
So let's talk a little bit
about machine learning.
The model was built by
Android and DeepMind
to predict which apps
go into which buckets.
Now we could have done this
with simple heuristics,
or we could have even just used
past behavior on the device.
But we found that
machine learning
allows us to capture
the nuance of how
users behave with their apps.
And I'll go into
some detail on how
we built the model in a second.
For those of you who are
interested in the architecture
of the model, we're using a
two-layer, deep convolutional
neural net with a feed
forward neural net on top.
And this is used to predict the
probability that an app will
be opened in a given interval.
You might have heard of
convolutional neural nets
before.
Particularly, they're quite
common in image classifiers.
But we've used them
here to measure
higher levels, higher level
patterns, of app usage
over time.
It turns out they're
pretty good at that.
Now all of this is happening
on device, using TensorFlow.
And that's actually
a first for DeepMind.
We've never deployed
a production model
on the compute power
of a single device.
And a single mobile device
within a limited compute power
that's available is a
particular set of challenges.
And of course, we're building
this machine learning model
with the intention of
attempting to save power.
And if we are doing
machine learning on device,
we have to be careful
that we're not spending
more power than we are saving.
We're going to be making this
model available to all device
manufacturers, so they
can take it, if they wish,
for their devices on
Android P, or they
can implement their own, or they
can take an Android open source
version of it as well.
So the model.
We trained the model on
millions of sequences of app
opens and transitions to
discover the patterns of how
your users behave.
So, an example would be, if
you use an app at 8 o'clock
in the morning,
every morning, you're
probably quite likely to open it
tomorrow at 8 o'clock as well.
But if you only use a
certain app on weekends,
like a game or a
travel app, then you're
probably not going to
open it on Monday morning.
And the model is able
to capture this nuance.
The model looks at
the user's behavior
and outputs a probability
of when you're next
going to open a particular app.
The model compares the
usage to the patterns
we've observed in the data,
and the behavior on device
will influence the predictions
given by the model.
So we've also built this
model with certain principles
in mind.
We try to make it fair.
There is no favoritism
of one app over another.
If you use one particular app
in exactly the same way that I
use a different
app, then the model
will output the
same predictions,
and they will be assigned
to the same buckets.
It's privacy-sensitive.
There's no personally
identifiable information
used by the model,
both when it's trained
and when it runs on the device.
The model only compares
the app usage on device
to our known sequences of
millions of app transitions,
and it predicts when you're
next going to use that app.
So if you combine
the App Standby
buckets and their restrictions
with this model that
predicts when you're next
going to open the apps,
that's the adaptive
battery feature.
It's a system that
adapts the phone to you.
The output of the model is used
to personalize the OS' behavior
to adapt it to how
you use the phone.
So the apps that you use get
to run in the background,
and the apps that
you don't, don't.
We hope this will create
a more consistent battery
experience for users.
I'm now going to
pass over to Madan,
who's a product
manager on Android,
to talk about the
battery saver features.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
MADAN ANKAPURA: Good job.
Thank you, James.
So let's talk about
battery saver.
Many of us actually
run through the day.
And as we end
towards the day, we
realize that, oh, I won't
be able to actually make it.
And battery saver is there
to actually save you.
You remember those red
bars when our animations
that were janky in Oreo?
Who liked those?
So we got rid of them.
We also actually
turned off location.
That helps battery.
In addition to that, many
device-specific features,
like Ambient display as an
example, are also turned off.
All of these add up in order
to save battery and prolong
the device battery
so that you can
go back and charge the device.
We have also made some
changes in the UI,
so that you can live on
this more for longer.
Now you have a slider
that you can actually
increase all the way
to the right, which
probably allows you to stay
on this more if you choose to.
But what's also interesting
is, what we found is,
if an app is being used
by the user in this mode,
having a dark
theme really helps.
Our internal tests show that
apps using dark theme save
power compared with
the ones that don't.
So if you are a developer that
already supports dark theme,
please do think about
switching to dark theme
when you detect that the
device is in battery saver.
There are a few
commands that you
can use through adb to force
the device into battery saver
and test them.
And for those of you who
already support dark mode,
there are APIs, like
isPowerSaveMode,
and a broadcast that you can use
to switch your device, your app
theme to dark.
So let's jump into the
battery settings itself.
We think when a user actually
goes into a battery settings,
probably they are having
a bad battery day.
You want to make the user
very easy to take actions.
You want to keep
the UI simplified.
And we will tell you
exactly what applications
might be causing
their battery drain,
so it'll be much more
opinionated about these things.
And in addition to that,
as you scroll down,
we'll also be able to see how
long your batter will last,
and that number is also
powered by an ML model.
So let's jump into that
opinionated background
restrictions.
So we have some principles
upon which we have
built this particular feature.
User asks for controls.
They want to know like,
which app is doing what,
so that they can take
a quick action on them.
We also want to make sure that
apps that don't necessarily
target audio are also being
well-managed by the user.
And lastly, our
goal is to make sure
that apps don't get
restricted in the first place.
So that way, apps fundamentally
are better battery citizens.
So with P, we will actually
launch this feature
with two specific criteria.
The first one is, if your app
is still not targeting Oreo
and has a background service.
The second one is if
an app holds wakelocks,
or what we call are stuck
wakelocks for more than an hour
in the background.
Both of these are
very well understood
causes for battery drain.
There are more such reasons.
We today represent those reasons
within Play developer console,
and we call them Android Vitals.
So we are, in the future,
going to be looking
at many such signals
in order to incorporate
into coming up with new rules
for background restrictions.
So what does it mean
for your app in case
if the user decides
to restrict them?
As James talked about, jobs,
alarms, services, and network,
the apps will not be able to do
any of those in the background.
There are some
explicit intents--
for example, location
will not be delivered
to those applications.
So we are trying to minimize
the reasons why an app should
be able to use device resources
when it is in the background.
And lastly, if an app is in
the background and restricted,
it won't be able to use
foreground services.
So as I spoke earlier,
I hope many of you
are already familiar
with Android vitals.
If not, I would
strongly recommend
you to go take a look
into what signals
do we actually show
in there today,
and how your app is behaving.
We have heard many
success stories
of application developers
using this data in order
to improve their applications.
And we, in fact, use
some of these signals
internally also
to make OS better,
trying to figure it out
like, what kind of changes
we could be making in order
to have the right guardrails
within the OS to make sure
that apps necessarily don't
accidentally drain battery.
There was a session about it.
If you haven't had a
chance to listen to those,
please take a look
at that according.
So, we made the UI
simplify, but there
might be several of you who
would fall into as power users.
So you do like graphs and you
do like number of percentages,
so we do have it in
the old flow menus.
Now the graph is improved
via better predictions,
and the user can take
action from this screen
if you see any app that is not
necessarily that surprises you
as being consuming more battery.
So from here, you can
directly preemptively restrict
applications or unrestrict them.
This is a good user
control for users to have.
So how do you test for this?
Again, there is adb
commands that you
can use to put your app
to a restricted state,
or unrestrict them and test them
while they are in the state.
Note that even an app
that has been restricted
could still be used by the user
by launching them explicitly.
So you want to make sure
that they still work.
So we have gone through some
of the key features in P.
And what does it mean for you
as an app developer to continue
to actually deliver
your features using
various affordances that the
OS offers, like jobs, alarms,
and so on, and so forth.
What does it mean for you
to do a background work?
You might have actually
seen this flowchart
before been presented last year.
It literally went through,
what is it that you want to do,
and offered some choices.
We want to simplify
our recommendation.
And thanks to Jetpack, in
it we have a great tool.
So it's extremely
simplified now, hopefully.
So if you want to think
about doing anything
in the background,
we highly recommend
you to actually evaluate
WorkManager as a go-to thing.
And if you think it is something
that is really important
and must happen
now, of course, you
have the ability to use
foreground and services.
But note that if you
use foreground services,
you have to tell the user
why you are using it for,
because there will
be a notification,
and you'll have to
justify yourself as to why
you think it is important.
And now, because of that,
if you change your mind,
go back to WorkManager.
So if none of this works,
think about actually doing
the work when the app
actually is launched
and being actively
used by the user.
So the choices are
hopefully very simplified.
All of this really helps
us manage battery better,
and that will lead to having
a better battery life.
There have been some sessions
that have already happened,
so I want to call a
shout out to Jetpack,
which talks about WorkManager.
There was also a session
on Android vitals,
and there is a DevByte as video.
There is a detailed of
documentation of the features
that we talked about.
Please head over to
d.android.com/power.
And thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]